today on the matt walsh show kyle
rittenhouse takes the stand in his own
defense the d.a pulls out every dirty
trick in the book in an effort to
railroad and we'll discuss the latest in
the case today also a george floyd
biography is coming soon will it include
the part where he forced his way into a
woman's home and robbed her at gunpoint
i guess we'll find out and two couples
at an ivf clinic have a mix-up that
results in their babies getting swapped
plus youtube gets rid of the dislike
counter in order to protect the fragile
feelings of content creators like myself
which i really appreciate and workplace
masturbator jeffrey toobin appears on
cnn
with some highly ironic analysis of the
written house case we'll talk about all
that much more today on the matt walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know if you're using the internet
without it without expressvpn you're
leaving yourself exposed it really is
like you know running into the gas
station with the keys still in the
ignition and the door unlocked uh most
of the time you're probably fine but
what if you come back to see someone
driving with your car you never know
what will happen every time you connect
to an unencrypted network cafes hotels
airports any hacker on the same network
can gain access to your personal data
passwords financial information etc it
doesn't take much technical knowledge to
hack somebody just some cheap hardware
as needed a smart 12 year old could do
it i mean i couldn't do it but i'm
dumber than a smart 12 year old uh your
data is valuable hackers can make up to
a thousand dollars per person selling
personal info on the dark web
uh so why use expressvpn because it
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
hackers can't steal your sensitive data
it would take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past expressvpn's encryption which means
that you're you're pretty safe okay
you're pretty safe and you can if you
get expressvpn you are keeping yourself
secure that's the name of the game here
so secure your online data today by
visiting
expressvpn.comwalsh.exp
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
welsh you can get an extra three months
for free as well expressvpn.com walsh
in one of the most famous scenes from a
man for all seasons and perhaps the best
thomas more is arguing with his
son-in-law william roper about the
meaning and value of the law
and roper wants more to arrest a guy
that that he roper has judged as bad
though he can't explain what law the guy
has actually broken
more calmly explains that being bad
generally speaking isn't against the law
in and of itself you can't go arresting
people for that reason because that
would be that that would be against the
law to do roper indignant accuses more
of giving the devil the benefit of law
and moore says that he would indeed give
even the devil the benefit of law
roper looking to take the moral high
ground says that well he would cut down
every law in england to get to you know
get a chance to go after the devil if
that's what it takes to which moore
responds and says
when the last law was down the devil
turned round on you where would you hide
the laws all being flat this country is
planted thick with laws from coast to
coast and if you cut them down do you
really think you could stand upright in
the winds that blow then yes i'd give
the devil the benefit of law for my own
safety's sake
now i've thought about that scene a lot
as i watched the kyle rittenhouse case
it's clear now and has always been clear
to any honest observer that ridden house
committed no crime he's an innocent man
innocent boy really as he was only 17 at
the time of this incident
but the left to include the corporate
media big tech democrat party the d.a in
the case
they're willing to destroy the law rip
it to shreds cut down every law in the
united states if they have to to punish
kyle rittenhouse
now at least roper in a man for all
seasons wanted to cut down the law to
get to the devil which would have been a
bad enough idea as thomas moore
explained kyle rittenhouse though
is not the devil he is in fact a good
man even a hero as we'll talk about
today
the men he killed in self-defense were
far more devilish than he is
if anything then the left is cutting
down the law to defend the devil
but the effect will be the same in the
end if they succeed
we'll be a nation with no law a nation
with nothing that can call itself a
justice system
now there's plenty more to say about the
trial but let's begin by playing a few
important clips from yesterday
rittenhouse took the stand in his own
defense
no doubt a risky move to haven't
testified considering that the state had
totally failed to prove its case or even
provide enough evidence to justify
bringing the case in the first place
the defense as we know basic basic law
here the defense is not there
to prove anything it's up to the
prosecution to provide proof of the
crime if the prosecution can't and
certainly couldn't in this case
then that should be the end of it
there's really no need for the defense
to call a single witness much less put
the accused himself on the stand
that's the way it should work but that
depends on the jury understanding what
its role is supposed to be
and acting on that understanding without
any ulterior motives unfortunately you
can't always rely on that which is
probably why the defense tried to seal
the deal by putting kyle up there
having watched his entire testimony
though i can't get inside the minds of
the jurors it seems to me that the
gamble paid off
because kyle
didn't come across like a cold-blooded
murderer as he has been cast
he seemed very much as he is a kid
a kid who suffered a terrible trauma
and had to fight for his life
in the moment on the streets of kenosha
and is now having to fight for his life
once again
it's the kind of pressure that would
take an
unimaginable psychological toll on
anybody especially somebody so young
and that toll that burden was made
apparent early in kyle's testimony when
he broke down on the stand let's watch
that
once i take that step back i look over
my shoulder and
mr rosenbaum
mr rosenbaum was now running
from
my right side
um
and
i was cornered from in front of me with
mr zaminski
and there were
people right there
take a deep breath out
now that's what a panic attack looks
like for anyone who's not familiar
of course as expected left us on social
media if you're expecting them to have
any
humanity then you were sorely mistaken
they mocked him for this display
accusing him of crying crocodile tears
there are many posts like this one from
anna navarro
she said kyle rittenhouse shot and
killed anthony hubert 26 joseph
rosenbaum 36 and injured gage gross
krause now 27. think about how much
their loved ones have cried real anguish
and grief not crocodile tears
now it's funny to hear people like this
deride a kid for crying on the stand as
he faces false murder charges kyle
rittenhouse was violently attacked by a
mob had to defend himself with lethal
force and immediately upon doing that he
was in order to save his life
immediately upon doing that all of the
most powerful forces in society
conspired and have been conspiring to
conspiring to ruin him and take away his
freedom
in the face of this he cried
meanwhile people like anna if a stand-up
comedian tells a joke
or if a politician they don't like is
elected
or if you misgender them they'll break
down in tears so they cry all the time
about everything
wielding their fragile emotions like a
battering ram
yet they think they're in a position to
look with contempt on a kid who cries
while facing the kind of pressure that
the vast majority of humans on planet
earth have never faced
and will never face
we talked to yesterday about how the
word trauma is is way overused and
everyone's running around all the time
claiming how they're traumatized by
everything
well here is an appropriate
use this is an application for trauma
this is a kid who has suffered real
trauma
that night that is a traumatic
experience and what he's gone through
over the last year in this trial also
traumatic experience
one other point about this navarro
attempts to solicit sympathy for
rosenbaum and huber the two men who were
killed
the media has been playing this game for
a year trying to tug on our heartstrings
calling on us on us to mourn poor
rosenbaum and huber
so it becomes relevant then to point
because they have introduced this right
just just like in a trial and and now
we're in the court of public opinion
they have opened this door
here by by talking about how we should
feel so bad for rosenbaum and huber
and on that note it becomes relevant to
point out
that rosenbaum was not only a sex
offender but in fact a serial child
rapist
he molested and annually raped multiple
boys
he had just recently got out of prison
for sex crimes when this happened
okay so
he is a serial child rapist goes to
prison gets out of prison and then uh
and then one of the first things he does
is he tries to chase someone down and
kill them
to put it as generous as i can joseph
rosenbaum was a piece of human filth
i mean that's how i feel about child
rapists i don't know about you
huber was slightly better but only by
comparison uh rather than a child rapist
he was merely a repeat repeat domestic
abuser guilty of among other things
choking and strangling a woman
now these facts may not be relevant to
the shootings themselves but they are
relevant if we're being asked to feel
sympathy for the quote unquote victims
or feel any emotion towards them other
than contempt
ridden house was justified in his
actions that night because huber and
rosenbaum were violently attacking him
leaving him no choice as has been
incontrovertibly proven but it's also
worth noting that the world is a better
place
without people especially like joseph
rosenbaum in it
bad person
and it strikes me that the left mourns a
pedophile child rapist
only a few days after celebrating when a
different child molester's name was put
on a navy ship
harvey milk maybe eventually joseph
rosenbaum will get his own ship too
so these people really seem to be big
fans of child rapists you might start
drawing some conclusions about them
now back to the trial perhaps all we
really need to say in analyzing the
state's cross-examination is that they
actually spent time
questioning kyle
about the video games that he plays
which put him in the position of having
to explain to the d.a
that video games and real life are not
the same
isn't one of the things people do in
these video games try and kill everyone
else with your guns
yeah the video game it's just a video
game it's not real life
sir isn't it true that you've played
super mario world
is it not true that in that game you
jump on little mushroom men and kill
them
sir
establishing a pattern
so this is what grasping at straws looks
like and uh that was if anything that
was like the highly that was the best
moment from the d.a
uh maybe the whole trial that's like as
good as it got
it was an absurd and misleading line of
questioning but at least it wasn't a
grave constitutional violation the
constitutional violations happened at a
different point when the d.a began
questioning kyle about the fact that
kyle exercised his right to remain
silent after his arrest prosecutors
are not allowed to stand in front of a
jury and imply that silence is
incriminating because the whole point of
your right to remain silent
is that you are not being forced to
incriminate yourself
okay the judge then had to jump in and
remind the d.a of this fact
you need to account for this
your honor i don't want to i want a jury
here
he's commenting on my client's right to
remain silent
i know your honor i am making the point
that
after hearing everything in the case now
he's
tailoring his story to what has already
been introduced
the problem is this is a grave
constitutional violation
for you to talk about
the defendants silence
and that is and and you're right
you're right on the you're right on the
borderline
and you may
you may be over but uh it better stop
understood
this is
i can't think of the case the initial
case on it but it's uh this is not
permitted
now it's not often that you hear a judge
accuse a d.a of a grave constitutional
violation in open court that's how
things have gone to this trial
a little bit later on as the prosecutor
continued with lines of questioning that
were not admissible and which had been
he'd been warned to avoid by the judge
um continued along this path the judge
was then forced to intervene again
and this time he wasn't quite as kind
about it
why would you think that that made it
okay for you without any advance notice
to bring this matter before the
jury you are already you were i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country for 40
years 50 years i have no idea why you
would do something like that and it
gives
well i'll leave it at that
so i don't know what you're up to
now i think what he was going to say
there not to try to read his mind but um
maybe words to the effect of like if
there's a conviction here this is this
is an appeal all day long i mean
if there is somehow a conviction here a
a grave miscarriage of justice
the good news at least the whole lot of
bad news the good news at least is that
this is appealed all day long i mean
you've got you have the judge in the
case telling the prosecutor that he
committed a grave constitutional
violation
is that he said you you crossed the line
and did that
look there there are gray areas in life
there are times when the line between
good and bad you know the good guy and
the bad guy might not be as clear
this is not one of those times okay the
bad guys
may as well be wearing name tags that
say hi i'm the bad guy that's how brazen
all of this is
and that leads me to two final points
one is
you know what what are they what are
they really doing here why are they
going after this kid
well much of the prosecutor's
questioning revolved around the gun he
was using and how big it was and how
scary it was
you know he he he observes the
prosecutor does uh that kyle rittenhouse
had had a bigger gun than than what his
assailant had
so you had a you had a bigger gun i mean
he had a smaller gun so why were you
with the bigger gun worried about a
smaller gun well i don't know maybe
because a smaller gun when you fire it
would still kill me
it became clear as this was going on
that the second amendment is what he is
trying to prosecute
our second amendment right our right to
defend ourselves is on trial
much of his line of questioning was
about really about that
uh where kyle rittenhouse became he
wasn't even testifying about himself he
became a
they were he was being treated like a
constitutional scholar a firearms expert
kyle rittenhouse is a symbol
this is not about him personally
certainly isn't about the of the events
of that night or the facts of the case
he's a stand-in and he represents not
only the constitutional rights of the
left to test but also the kind of people
that the left detests
just like derek chauvin before him
written houses a blood sacrifice meant
to atone for the sins of all white men
his personal guilt or innocence is not
relevant
just as a goat sacrificed on a burning
altar is not selected due to its
personal foibles it is burned as a
symbol and that's the role that kyle is
playing here
second
all that should matter
in the case
is that kyle is not guilty of committing
murder
you know that should be the end of it
that's all that's all that matters
legally even if he was reckless or
stupid or he shouldn't have been there
quote unquote
uh even if he is a terrible person
even if he's the devil none of that
matters or should matter legally
and yet i still think it's important to
point out
that kyle rittenhouse
is is uh not a bad person and i don't
think he's even stupid or reckless and
he's not he's more than merely innocent
he's more than that i think he's a hero
in my estimation
yes he put he put himself in harm's way
by showing up to the riot
but where i come from putting yourself
in harm's way in order to defend
innocent people and protect property is
heroic
that's what heroes do that's like the
definition of a hero
and yes to protect property too it tells
you a lot about you know
a lot people on the left that they
and we get this from the prosecutor a
lot too well you would use violent force
to protect property it's just property
well again he used the violence force to
protect human life his own life
that's why he had the gun was to protect
himself
but um but you know what you know
something yeah i mean using force to
protect property that is also morally
justified it's not only morally
justified it's heroic
what does the mob have some kind of
right well the mob all they want to do
is burn down buildings
they have no right to do that
this this people's property this is
their livelihood their lives their
businesses that are being destroyed
yes you could
i would use lethal force to protect if
someone was trying to burn down my home
i would shoot them i would even if there
was nobody else inside
why because it's my home it's my
property
and you have no right to do what you're
doing right now
and i can use force to stop you and i
would
but even when faced with a mortal threat
from a violent mob still ridden house
waited until the very last moment to
fire
he tried to preserve the lives of a
people who wanted him dead
until they left him no recourse
i would call that courage not stupidity
though to cowards perhaps
it's hard to tell the difference between
the two
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know i don't mean to scare you but
these days there are surveillance apps
out there known as stalkerware and they
can collect information from you while
avoiding det detection by pretending to
be something else soccerware sits
silently in the background collecting
data doing things like recording calls
and keystrokes stealing your photos
sending the info it gathers to whoever
is spying on you every day we put our
information
at risk on the internet in ways like
this in an instant a cyber criminal
could steal what's yours sometimes even
harm your finances your credit your
reputation they can really ruin your
life in a lot of ways and that's why
it's so good that there is lifelock
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats uh things that you
wouldn't know about or even think about
like if your social security number is
for sale on the dark web
if they detect the information has been
compromised they will send you an alert
and they will help you to uh to fix the
problem and make it very easy for you
you don't want to use the internet
without lifelock nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can help protect what's yours with
lifelock by norton join now and save up
to 25 off your first year by going to
lifelock.com welsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 percent off all right um so
this is kind of exciting i i just got
the news yesterday from my dentist that
i got to go i have to get some root
canals next week so i got two root
canals i'm uh in line for i don't know
it's it it feels very adult you know
i've heard so much about the root canals
you always compare uh it's worse than a
root canal never had i've never even had
a cavity before so
um and here's the thing when i when i do
something i go all in i'm fully
committed so if i'm gonna have a cavity
might as well get a root canal type
cavity
and um so that was my first reaction
that this feels like a this feels like a
new step into adulthood in some way
and i i guess i i would be the guy
i'm such a committed contrarian that i
would be the guy to enjoy a root canal
that would be my ultimate contrarian
take
actually root canals are good
but then the problem is i was talking to
a dentist and he told me that
i don't know why he said this he
shouldn't have said it
but he said you know uh
yeah you could you could just do nothing
if you want that is an option
just don't do anything
you could do that
i said really that's
you're putting that on the table like i
got this situation i could just do
nothing at all and live my life
don't don't tell me that like don't as a
doctor that's the worst thing you could
say to me
when i when i blew up my achilles the
doctor said the same thing he's like
technically you know yeah i mean we have
the surgery it's a big surgery
technically you could do nothing we have
to tell you that's an option and i
seriously considered it and i'll tell
you why because there's this combination
for me i i hate doctors
i mean i hate going to doctors i mean
not anything against doctors personally
i don't like going to the doctor
i'm also very lazy and then and then i
and then i have this this this
this gross overestimation of my own pain
tolerance and so all those things
combined to if you give me an excuse
i'll just yeah i'll just live with it
until my teeth fall out if you give if
you put that on the table so
now i'm uh
now that's just something i have to
balance i suppose all right
uh but my wife does have a she she has a
pretty firm opinion on it which is i
don't want your teeth followed okay
we'll start with this from the daily
wire
this says a biography of george floyd
will be published on march 17th
so look forward to that put the put that
on your calendar um to go out and run
pick the george floyd biography up
and it appears to whitewash his life
store to highlight his constant search
of a better life and his relentless
struggle to survive as a black man in
america
in a press relief release a viking press
a publishing company owned by penguin
house announced the biography which is
written by robert samuels and toulouse
olu runepa two prize-winning washington
post reporters the book is designed to
reveal how systemic racism shaped george
floyd's life and legacy from his
family's roots in the tobacco fields of
north carolina to ongoing inequality in
housing education health care criminal
justice and policing telling the
singular story of how one man's tragic
experience brought about a global
movement
of change and so now this is when we're
going to get
uh the whole hagiography of of george
floyd i mean this is
this is an important point i mean this
is an important step when you're when
you're building this myth
because so far
with the mythology of george floyd
saint george floyd
uh they have the martyr story
which is mostly false
but the whole rest of his life they've
kind of ignored
and so now finally these washington post
reporters who as washington post
reporters are we know that they are very
experienced fiction writers
and so now they're going to to write
this work of fiction and they've got
their work they've got their work cut
out for them
in in some ways
how are you going to take this man
who was a terrible person
terrible
and contributed nothing of value to
society whatsoever
and rather than in fact rather than
contributing things of value to his
community he preyed upon the most
helpless and vulnerable people in his
community how are you going to take that
and somehow morph it into
a hero's journey
so i almost
would want to read the book just out of
curiosity to see how they do it
i'm not going to do that because i value
my time too much and i wouldn't i
wouldn't spend the money on it but
um yeah a struggle to survive as a black
man in america this is about so is that
searching for a better life
is that the chat when we get to the
searching for a better life you know
part two searching for a better life
is that the part where he forces his way
into a woman's home and robs her at
gunpoint in front of her kid
he was just searching for a better life
don't mind me ma'am i'm just searching
for a better life
now hand me over all your money
but you know it is it's true in in in a
way um
that in
some of in in these communities in
cities
um as a black man
or really if you live in these
communities at all no matter your race
there is a struggle to survive that's
true these could be dangerous places
but it's a struggle to survive
because of guys like george floyd
they're the ones who create that
struggle
i mean they're the ones you're worried
about
despite no matter what anybody says
no matter what they claim about how
they're uh we
we fear that we fear the police no i
mean if you are a woman
living in uh living in the inner city
you're not worried about the police
you're worried about george floyd
breaking into your house
all right um
so i'm not usually one to talk about
news from the fashion world but there
was a point i wanted to make about this
i thought it was somewhat interesting
this is from msn
it says tom ford says cancel culture
inhibits design the 60 year old fashion
muse behind the iconic label
says the the fact everything is now
considered appropriation is limiting
fashion
speaking to the guardian ford said
cancel culture inhibits design because
rather than feeling free the tendency is
to start uh locked into a set of rules
everything is now considered
appropriation we used to be able to
celebrate other cultures and now we
can't do that
he says the future of fashion is
increasingly cartoonish instagram has
broken down the rules people dress up to
take pictures of themselves to post
online everything is exaggerated
especially the eyebrows uh so it's it
says this is the
future of fashion it's very cartoonish
and i mean just not as a fashion expert
myself but just by observation you would
seem to be right about that
uh but also
it's it's it's impossible now because of
these rules of appropriation
and this is the nature of
style you know it is it's
it's something that's it's always a
fusion there's always different
influences that you're bringing together
right
and now we're drawing these lines and
saying well no if you're
if you're a white person you're not
allowed to wear anything that has any
kind of influence from the outside world
which means that basically you gotta
walk around naked which is great news if
you're you know jeffrey tubin but for
most of us it's not so good
because no matter what you're wearing no
matter what you're eating no matter what
music you're listening to
it is always going to be the result of
at least some kind of fusion some kind
of outside influence because these
things are
are human
inventions human constructions
um
whether we're talking about you know
the culinary world or fashion or music i
mean these are art
and people
are
influenced by by the world around them
you know i i was reading an article
recently and i almost did it for a daily
cancellation but then i figured it's
just there's there's really no point
what else can i say about this other
than how stupid it is
but um
one of these media outlets they were
very concerned about
um appropriation
that parents are committing
in in how they wear their babies
you know baby wearing
is a is a thing where if you you know
you could with one of those backpacks or
you it's there's there's different
things that that parents can do makes a
lot easier because it frees up your
hands uh you can strap the baby you know
onto your chest or onto your back
and uh and go about your day and you
might think
that the only thing to worry about there
when you're wearing the baby is just to
make sure it's safe and you've got
everything strapped together so that the
baby doesn't fall
but apparently no this is a very this is
a very fraught area because there's a
lot of cultural appropriation and so
this article was concerned with letting
parents know if you're a white parent
make sure that you're not appropriating
you're not accidentally being racist in
how you choose to wear babies
that's absurd as guy but there's also
another point too that um
you know he's talking about the style
world i don't know much about that
but what you find in general is that
cancel culture makes everything boring
i guess it does that with style it also
just does that with with opinions with
discussion
that's one of the i think underrated
aspects and consequences of cancel
culture
uh yes it's very tyrannical it's very
limiting people are afraid but also
in the midst of all of that
as people are trembling in fear and not
wanting to say anything that will upset
anybody everything just becomes so
boring all discussions become so so
aggressively relentlessly boring
and why is that because people are
afraid to experiment with ideas
uh to use the cliche they're afraid to
kind of think outside the box
because that's in the past that's
actually how that's that's part of the
process of figuring out how you feel
about things and what your ideas are
sometimes in order to do that it
involves you first expressing an idea
that maybe you're not 100 sure about
and you say hey i was just thinking this
here's my opinion on this i'm not
exactly sure but here's a thought that i
had
[Music]
and then you have a discussion and
through that discussion you start to
kind of hone it a little bit
and mold it and shape it
but you can't do that anymore
you can't go out there with an outside
of the box thought where you're kind of
experimenting with ideas
everybody is looking for cover in a
crowd
that's one of the reasons why people
stay in their echo chambers
it's especially why people
who have a platform
and speak in front of cameras
why they try to stay in their echo
chamber
because there's
there's protection there you can hide
behind other people
um
and you find this on the right too it's
not just on the left
there's a lot of this that goes on in
the right
in fact you can notice this i'm very
sensitive to it i don't know how much
you because i'm in this world but i'm
not sure how how obvious it is to people
outside
of uh this business but
i notice you know like conservative
commentators something happens there's a
new event
um
say like the cal written house case or
something and you've got a lot of
conservatives who will they kind of wait
they don't want to say anything at first
they have an opinion they have a
perspective they don't say anything they
they kind of they wait for someone to be
the first one to say something
express an opinion and a few others say
and then they jump in and say okay well
i can have that opinion now
because at least if they come after me
i've got some company
and it just makes everything very boring
uh all discussions everything you know
there's there's no matter what side
you're on
you have your approved opinions that you
know you can say and it's safe because
everybody says that
um
and that's where everybody that's the
zone everybody lives in and it becomes
very boring all right this is from the
new york post says two couples spent
months raising baby girls who weren't
theirs after a mix-up at a los angeles
fertility clinic
which implanted the mothers with each
other's embryos during in vitro
fertilization according to a lawsuit
daphna cardinali said that she and her
husband alexander quickly suspected that
the girl she gave birth to in late
2019 wasn't theirs because she had a
darker complexion than they do
alexander said during a news conference
i had a weird sort of a gut reaction
when she was born it wasn't anything
logical it was just like an instinct
in the delivery room he had expected a
fair child like their firstborn but he
was surprised to see the baby girl come
out with much darker skin
it was so jarring that alexander
actually took several steps away from
the birthing table
backing up against the wall
um
i guess this isn't funny but i'm
trying hard not to
laugh at this situation but the parents
ignored their doubts because they fell
in love with the infant and trusted
their doctors i was overwhelmed by
feelings of fear betrayal anger and
heartbreak that a distraught woman said
adding that she suffered trauma when she
found out months later that she had
carried another woman's baby and that
the other woman had her child
and now this is working his throat way
through the court system
you know they're of course
the fertility clinic
is going to be sued out of existence and
and you know rightfully so this is a
pretty
when it comes to
customer service mistakes
um in planting the wrong baby in a
woman's uterus
pretty high up there you know that's a
it's a little bit worse than delivering
a pizza later or something
but it does
maybe raise some questions
about
ivf as a concept
when you have a procedure where this can
even happen
this is something through modern
technology we've created this is a risk
that never could have happened before in
human history there was no there was no
chance now
for for for thousands of years of human
history right
uh there was a chance this is this
something that that fathers might have
had to worry about that the baby that's
uh in the womb is not theirs
but you never had you never had a mother
who had to worry that the baby wasn't
hers
now because of of ivf this is obviously
doesn't happen very often we would we
would hope
but it's kind of it's a it's a
possibility that we have created
and it's a possibility we've created
because that's what happens when you
move
the very human act of conception
out of
its natural confines
and you do it in a petri dish
maybe that's kind of a red flag about
this sort of procedure
and
because what we're actually doing
and the reason why i don't like ivf why
i'm not a fan of it
is because not just i'm not a fan of it
i object to it on moral grounds
because it's the commodification of
human life
you're quite literally treating human
life like a commodity
in the most literal sense
and you have you know you you have a
bunch of embryos
and and then and then
what happens maybe this mix-up
kind of thing this freaky friday mix-up
thing doesn't happen very often but what
does happen all the time is that you've
got a bunch of uh of embryos and then
you have and then you have leftover
embryos that gets stored in a freezer
like uh you know like ground beef that
you're not gonna have time to cook up
and uh it just stays there for a while
and then eventually if they're never
used okay and think about the language
here
the embryos are never used
um then they'll be destroyed
so
this is the reduction of human life down
to a commodity
being treated very much like an object
where we talk about you know you could
have a surplus of it what do you do with
the surplus you just destroy them
um
it's it's hard
and i admit this
if you come at
if you if you
approach life from a materialist
perspective
and all you see when you look at human
beings all you see is material you think
that you think that's all we are
in fact all we are
all you are is is an object if that's
how you see it then
yeah from from that starting point it's
going to be hard for me to convince you
that something like ivf might be morally
problematic
but if you see life as more than that if
you're not a materialist
then i think there's a reason to be
skeptical of anything that reduces life
down to mere material
all right next this is from techcrunch i
think this is good news i'm very uh very
happy about this it says youtube today
announced its decision
to make the dislike count on videos
private across its platform
the decision is likely to be
controversial given the extent that it
impacts the public's visibility into a
video's reception so if you're watching
this on youtube right now if this is
correct then you should not be able to
see how many people disapprove of my
show the bit what i just talked about
with ivf there's gonna be a lot of
people that don't agree either even on
my side
and now guess what
you're not gonna know how many disagree
with it
and i and i personally
am a fan of that
it says but youtube believes the change
will be will will better protect its
creators from harassment and reduce the
threat of what it calls
dislike attacks essentially when a group
teams up to drive up the numbers of
dislikes a video receives
the company says that while dislike
accounts won't be visible to the public
it's not removing the dislike button so
you can still dislike
but nobody will see that you disliked it
and then we as youtube creators will
have to go back into our youtube studio
dashboard and we can look up that
information if we want to but but i
won't look it up because i i don't want
to know
it's better not to know
so your dislike it will be sent off into
the void
the dislike itself will be stored
basically in a cyber freezer and i will
never go it'll just stay there i'll
never look at it you'll i will never
know
and you know there are some people
saying that this is kind of absurd but
but you know and you might hear a phrase
like dislike attack
or when a thumbs down is equated to
harassment you might think that sounds
pretty absurd and silly but you know
it's easy for you to say if you're not a
youtube creator as someone who is on
this platform every single day
you just have no idea
what kind of emotional and psychological
toll it takes on a person to see all
those thumbs down
i i i cry every day
when i check my videos if i see even one
i shed a tear for every thumbs down i
get
it is deeply traumatic
and so i want to thank youtube for
finally standing up for us and for our
feelings
uh now let's
dive into the comment
their
section
they're the sweet baby gang
as you know people always tell me that
uh one of the things i really love that
i love about the show is the passion
that i bring to uh the subject that i
talk about especially when we're talking
about mortgage refinancing and that's
what we're talking about right now
american financing america's home for
home loans uh new sponsor on the show
we're very excited about the home you're
living in right now can cost you less
it's true you can lower your payment and
save thousands the long term you just
have to refinance one of these
incredibly low mortgage rates and do it
now before they're gone uh they're
expected to rise in the new year you
cannot afford to miss out on this deal
it takes just a 10 minute call to
american financing america's home for
home loans for me the call takes longer
because i spend a lot of time gabbing
about the subject but if you want to be
in and out you can you'll work with a
salary based mortgage consultant someone
who will guide you through custom loan
options that can save you up to a
thousand dollars a month that's right a
thousand dollars a month and you don't
have to reset your loan to get those
kinds of savings you can choose any term
10 years and over because you shouldn't
pay interest for years that you don't
need pre-qualify for free at
866-569-4711 that's 866 569 4711 or
visit americanfinancing.net
all right
jennifer says matt you're smart enough
to know the derrick chauvin case was the
end of our justice system now let's see
if you're brave enough to admit it
uh well i think the derek chovin case
was a blow to our justice system
um
and i as you know believe that derek
chovin should have been acquitted
but
you know i i think you're you're really
underestimating and understating what's
happening with the cal written house
case
by looking at this as a one-to-one
comparison i mean what's happening with
kyle rittenhouse and he hasn't been
convicted yet and we're praying that
he's not but
if he is convicted it would be even even
more egregious i mean for example in the
derek shoving case
you didn't have any scenes like what we
just played where the judge says that
there's a grave constitutional violation
happening right now in this case
so
in terms of how egregious and blatant
and out in the open it is
i don't think we've ever seen anything
quite like the carl rittenhouse case
so i think this would be kind of the
nail in the coffin in my opinion
um
carla says talking about the video
yesterday we played of the boy in the
dress with the abusive mother it's clear
that the boy in the opening video has
been coached by his mother she dressed
him up and paraded him before the camera
in order to satisfy her own sick ego
what i want to know is where is that
boy's father either he's absent in the
boy's life or he's a weak and a pitiful
excuse for a man
yeah well you always know that anytime
you see
any of these
it's not a coincidence
that in the vast majority of cases when
you see these uh these poor little kids
being paraded around
on camera on tik-tok instagram on you
know in in the media
[Music]
these poor little boys dressed up like
girls with makeup and everything
um it's not a coincidence that it's
almost always the mom alone
doing this
she's off she's the one on camera she's
the one holding the camera
and what that tells us is that is that
100
this is a 100 certainty
the father is absent from that home 100
certainty
now he he may still be a physical
presence i think very often he's absent
in every sense of the word
but there may be cases where he is a
physical presence but he is still absent
there's there's no real there's there
might be a man a guy in that house
physically sitting around
like a lump on a log but there's no
father in that home there's no real
father because a real father would put
an end to that
immediately
um
you know i don't
i am not one to recommend divorce um but
you know you're a father
and your wife tries to dress your boy up
like a girl that's that's one of those
drawing lines ultimatums
you're not going to do this to my son
this is not going to happen
um all right spazzio says i think you
need to show some proof of the claims
you made about alfred kinsey it's the
second time you claim he's not a valid
scientist and his research is pure
nonsense there's no legit documentation
on the internet that back up your
thoughts and this is a really unsettled
argument because of that well spazio yes
there is
you know i
i'm not gonna hold your hand through
this increasingly i'm just annoyed with
people you say what's your source give
me
just spend five minutes looking it up
yourself why don't you i can't hold your
hand
yeah everything i said about alfred
kinsey a hundred percent factual
okay but you're gonna yeah you're gonna
spend a little bit of time i can't see
what you want is you want me to give you
a link with the bullet points and so
that you could spend five seconds and
you could read three sentences and say
oh well there it is
now this is one of those things you got
to spend a little bit more time to
understand the full history of you know
of alfred kinsey and the sexual
revolution and how it takes a little bit
in fact you might even have to read
some books about it you might have to
read an entire book if you really want
to understand it
but what i can tell you is that what i
said again is
is a fact um
you know his methodology
when he released uh uh
you know sexual behavior in the human
mail
and the methodology that he used
the the the
the populations
the segments of the population that he
was studying
and gathering all of his survey data
from
this is it's not disputed
um
let's see what else do we got
zuko says it's very hard to maintain
control at the video of the poor abused
four-year-old it's amazing though that
she gave us the nice comparison of his
age though he's clearly confused because
he's for his mom insists on changing
definitions on him right that's exactly
the point eric says i bet 99 of people
who've seen eternals had no idea it was
directed by a woman yeah that's the
other point about the the claim from the
film critic yesterday this this marvel
movie eternals that apparently nobody
likes and nobody wants to see
and the critic says well it's because
it's directed by a woman people are
sexist
and as i said yesterday the exact opps
is the case but critics especially bend
over backwards to find any reason they
can to
give a good review to a movie that's
directed by a woman but as far as the
audience goes this just shows that kind
of the bubble that these film critics
live and they don't understand how the
average film
uh moviegoer actually experiences movies
the average moviegoer has no idea who
the director is of any of these movies i
i bet if you went up to just the average
moviegoer the average person who watches
movies which is most people and you ask
them to name
like five directors they probably
couldn't even name five they might be
able to give you three
like i could tell you steven spielberg
but maybe they could give you
christopher nolan i mean this just cause
most people don't it doesn't matter to
them that much
um
and uh they certainly aren't aren't
looking up information about the
director and then saying well this one
was directed by a woman well i'm not
going to watch this
that's not what people are doing
outside of the the bubble that you're
living in when it comes to biden's
vaccine mandates the daily wire isn't
backing down you heard us talking about
this yesterday if you watched the
backstage show we filed our lawsuit
against the tyrannical and
unconstitutional mandates a week ago
today and we're already seeing results
the fifth circuit court of appeals
issued a temporary stay
over the weekend preventing the blind
biden's mandate from going into effect
citing grave statutory and
constitutional issues there seems to be
a lot of those going around today this
uh does not mean the battle is over
rather the battle has just begun biden
is determined to pass these mandates no
matter what and that's why we have to
keep fighting we're not we're not just
fighting for the daily wire employees
we're fighting for the medical freedom
of every single brave american and it's
extremely important that everyone
makes their voice heard right now this
is an urgent matter and your medical
freedom depends on it if you want to
support the fight to make your personal
medical decisions without government
interference sign our petition against
biden's authoritarian mandate hundreds
of thousands of americans have already
signed the petition in just a few days
but we need many more people to stand up
just to reach our goal so please head to
dailywire.com
do not comply to sign the petition today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel once again
cnn uh this time for a segment on the
kyle rittenhouse case featuring one mr
jeffrey toobin as you recall though you
surely wish you did not recall tubin cnn
legal analyst gained international
notoriety last year when he was caught
uh badgering the witness during a zoom
meeting with his co-workers tuban
tubin pulled his tube out you might say
he tried to to put a gently uh get a
hold of himself during this meeting
he's always been a self-congratulatory
type so he decided to give himself a
hand so to speak and while he was
engaged in this diy project his
colleagues looked on in
unimaginable shock and heart
now for most humans on earth
handling your situation in a work
setting in full view of other employees
would lead not only to immediate
termination but it would likely
foreclose all future possibilities of
employment
you could maybe get a job as assistant
manager at your local sex shop i don't
know though on second thought you
certainly could not be trusted in that
setting either so really that would be
it for you
you may never find gainful employment
ever again but jeffrey toobin works in
corporate media and the roles the rules
are different there which means that in
this case he was back on the beat with
uh cnn within just a few months cnn has
mostly not seen it necessary to justify
its decision to employ and provide a
public platform to a man who masturbated
during a work meeting to the extent that
they've bothered to explain it the
rationale seems to be that tuban's
behavior was an accident he's the real
victim here you see
he didn't know that his camera was on
during the zoom call he thought he was
uh debugging the hard drive in the
privacy of his own home and it may
indeed be true that he didn't know the
camera was on
but
the act itself was not an accident
granted i was not on the call which is
why i still have eyes and i haven't
gouged them out
but i still feel safe assuming that
tubin didn't slip and fall and
accidentally masturbate no he quite
intentionally decided to perform that
act during a work meeting
while watching his co-workers
the only thing he didn't intend was for
them to know that he was doing it
i fail to see how that makes this any
better
i mean if there's a guy
on public transportation sitting in the
back of the bus masturbating
hoping no one sees it someone does can
he say to the cop well i didn't mean for
anyone to know that i was doing it
especially because we can assume here
as always is the case in this kind of
situation that when a pervert is caught
in the act for the first time
he was only caught for the first time
it's not however his first time at the
rodeo
and yet he's back on the air which leads
us finally to this segment and uh let's
all watch cautiously
jeffrey two thoughts two thoughts one
what kind of idiot
17 year old gets a giant gun and goes to
a riot he has no license he has no
training he thinks he's going to scrub
graffiti off with his ar-15 i mean the
stupidity of this looks like what could
possibly go wrong well a lot went wrong
the good news for kyle rittenhouse is
that he's not on trial for being an
idiot he's on trial for homicide and in
that respect i mostly agree with joey
that
this is a tough case for the prosecution
because
it does seem like it he has a plausible
case of self-defense and you know if
if it were illegal to be an idiot the
jails would be even freer
even more crowded than they are now
homicide's a different matter
very bold move by cnn to use a glass
table um
also you have to feel bad for the guy
sitting right next to tubin
as tube is kind of waving his hands
around like that
his life must been flashing before his
eyes which is still better than tuban
flashing before his eyes i suppose as
for two but he accuses rittenhouse of
being an idiot
now just to emphasize here the man who
pleasured himself during a zoom meeting
and forgot to turn the camera off is
calling somebody else an idiot
he says it's fortunate for written house
that you know being an idiot isn't
illegal well it's fortunate for tubin
that masturbating in front of unwilling
spectators isn't illegal oh wait it is
illegal
just not if you're a member of the
favored class
now putting his childish analysis of the
written house case aside i mean you can
really see why cnn just had to bring the
masturbator back on the air because
otherwise they'd be deprived of
insightful legal opinions like that
guy's an idiot
lol but putting that aside
jeffrey toobin really shows us the
nature of cancel culture doesn't he
jeffrey tubin shows us
quite a lot actually way more than we
want to see but the lesson he provides
about cancer culture is useful cancer
culture is as i've always said arbitrary
by definition why is louis ck still
banished to the cultural hinterlands
persona non grata and yet tubin is on
cable news they did the same thing but
tuban is arguably worse because he
didn't get consent ahead of time
and there have certainly been people who
committed far less severe infractions or
no infraction and yet suffer punishments
far worse than whatever tuban suffered
which was really nothing at all when it
comes to workplace sexual harassment
specifically we live in a world now
where giving your female co-worker a
compliment
maybe sexual harassment but i mean in in
tubin's case
masturbating in front of her during a
work meeting is not sexual harassment
but this is all by design it's a power
move by cnn really cancel culture is
arbitrary it's also left-wing inherently
it was largely invented by the left-wing
corporate media it's their thing
cancel culture belongs to cnn and its
fellow corporate media organizations it
will decide who is canceled and who is
not
jeffrey tubin is on their team
they happen to like him for whatever
reason and so they will grant him a pass
that nobody else i mean nobody else on
the planet anywhere would be granted
there's no coherent moral philosophy
underpinning this cancel culture isn't
it's not it's not mere left-wing
puritanism
it's not even a moral panic
it's a weapon
and they will decide how to wield it
that's why tubin still has a job
and it's probably still invited on zoom
calls
and everybody else in the call just has
to make sure that they don't eat lunch
beforehand i guess
that's also why i must say again today
that cnn is of course cancelled i'll
leave it there for today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
kyle rittenhouse clears his name a major
publisher commissions a hagiography of
george floyd and biden's vaccine mandate
might cost nearly 40 percent of truckers
their jobs amid a supply chain crisis
right around christmas check it out on
the michael knowles show